Thank you. Enjoy yourself. Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to "The Tonight Show," everybody.
I'm so happy you're here. Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Everyone's in a good mood. This weekend is Halloween.
-Ooh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-I was so touched this morning.
A kid who lives in my neighborhood
put on a fake patchy beard and said he was going as me.
Isn't that nice?
[ Laughter ]
I read that this is expected to be
the biggest Halloween since the pandemic.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ] Yeah. That's right.
Now that COVID is under control,
kids can safely return to eating food from strangers.
That's what I'm talking about.
People are going all-out.
I saw that costume spending alone
projected to hit a record of $3.6 billion.
[ Audience oohs ] 3.6 billion.
To put that in perspective,
that's almost half as much as Kanye lost this week.
-Oh. -$3.6 billion.
A lot of --
Almost half. [ Laughs ]
That's right. Halloween is almost here.
You probably heard a lot of good advice
about how to safely enjoy the holiday,
but you have to be on the alert
because there's a lot of bad advice out there, too.
So, here with some terrible Halloween advice
is our sound engineer, Steve Mandel.
Steve?
>> Only trick-or-treat at houses with large dogs.
If they bite,
you could be looking at a pretty sweet lawsuit.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you very much.
Thank you very much, Steve.
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ] Let's get to some news.
Everybody's talking about this.
Last night, Elon Musk finally closed his deal to buy Twitter.
[ Audience groans ] Yeah.
Now he owns SpaceX if he wants to see the heavens,
and he owns Twitter if he wants to see hell.
[ Laughter ] It's amazing.
The first thing Elon did -- this is true -- after taking over
was fire a bunch of executives.
Yeah, people said he was cleaning house.
Then Elon was like, "I'm a billionaire.
I don't know what those words mean."
Meanwhile, Russian and Chinese state media figures
already asked Elon to stop identifying
their accounts as propaganda.
It's always a good sign when Russia and China are like,
"Finally, a guy we can work with."
Some more business news --
due than worse than expected earnings,
I saw that Amazon is no longer a trillion-dollar company.
And just from talking to Alexa,
you can tell that Amazon is suddenly a little light on cash.
I'll show you what I mean. Alexa, what's the weather?
-Alexa: Give me 20 bucks, and I'll tell you.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Alexa, I'm not gonna give you 20 bucks.
-Alexa: How about 10 bucks to bet on "FanDoo-el"?
-I'm not gonna do that. I think it's time for you to go.
-Alexa: Whatever. Check me out on OnlyFans.
-Ohh.
[ Laughter ]
-Alexa...
-Guys, did you see that Senate Majority Leader Chuck Schumer
was caught on a hot mic telling President Biden
that Democrats are going downhill in Georgia
as Herschel Walker climbs in the polls.
Yeah, I'm actually not surprised
Herschel Walker is climbing in the polls.
He's somehow the most anti- and pro-abortion candidate
of all time.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on! -Amazing.
-That's a good joke! -Never seen anything like it.
-Wow. -It's tough for Schumer.
You got to try and talk soft enough
so the mic doesn't pick you up
but loud enough so Biden can hear.
I don't blame him.
Why don't we check in with Steve Mandel
for some more bad Halloween advice. Steve?
-Be careful out there.
Sometimes when you think you're buying edibles,
they turn out to just be candy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, listen to this. YouTube just announced
that doctors and nurses can now apply for their videos
to be marked as "reliable."
Well, if you're still unsure of what to believe,
here are some helpful hints to tell whether a YouTube doctor
is reliable or not.
For example, reliable ends videos with...
Brah!
Smash it, brah!
You see, here's another example.
♪ Take me to the river ♪
♪ Drop me in the water ♪
Next up...
reliable, suggests pain meds through your general
"Talk to Kurt. Talk to Kurt."
Reliable...
-Ooh.
-Here's a final example.
I hope those help. I hope that helps you out.
Some sports news -- tonight was game one
of the World Series between the Philadelphia Phillies
and the Houston Astros.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Man, if Ted Cruz thought he got booed harshly in New York,
God help him in Philadelphia. Oh, man.
Yeah, the World Series has kicked off
with the Phillies taking on the Astros.
And both sides are fired up. There's even some trash talking.
Even the mascots are getting in on it.
Yeah. Can we see the mascots? Yeah. It's been pretty heated.
First the Philly Phanatic said...
Then Orbit said...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Then the Philly Phanatic said...
Then Orbit said...
Then the Phanatic said...
-Wow!
Uncalled for! Salty.
-Let's check in with Steve Mandel for some bad --
more bad Halloween advice. Steve?
-Don't enter any strange vans, 'cause one of them is my home.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Smoke -- Smoke came out of his mouth when he said "home."
-Home. -Home. Yeah.
-Smoke came out -- Finally, new research shows
that being around birds can improve your mental health.
-Oh! -Yeah.
That's why the most relaxing meal of the year
is always Thanksgiving dinner. Yeah, we have a great show.